un gesto que pensábamos perdido un
hábito que pertenecía a la vida del
pasado pero poco a poco en la mitad de
las calles en una tarde con amigos o
hasta en el elíseo el peso vuelve a
resurgir para muchos franceses besar en
la mejilla para saludar es una prueba
irrefutable de afecto durante la
pandemia del hobbit no volvía a saludar
con beso como una medida de seguridad
pero ahora lo vuelvo a hacer con
personas que conozco no con gente que no
conozca el fondo blanco min durante
mucho tiempo hasta mi hija guardaba la
distancia ya insta el fin tengo sólo una
hija de 32 años que guarda la distancia
con migo que no quería saludarme de eso
era muy triste
[Música]
o el saludo con beso en la mejilla es
una tradición francesa que a veces
sorprende a otros países europeos antes
de la crisis sanitaria paul taylor un
hombre británico con buen sentido del
humor se divertía con esta costumbre
hola me llamo paul y vivo en francia y
una de las cosas que más me enfurece en
acá es lápiz la manera de saludar lo
peor de todo es que cuando tomas una
copa con tus amigos antes de tomar
cualquier cosa tienes que saludar a todo
el mundo uno a uno
a pesar de las múltiples innovaciones en
materia de salud o estás nuevas maneras
de saludar nunca vencerán el apego de
los franceses hacia el beso en la
mejilla